2 frattina
[Musica]
riparativa fatto da tanti mano
ha smesso di parlarsi per scopi hanno
anche prendere un bicchiere delle due
navi
ordinaria finocchio hanno sempre aperto
il problema mi amano
che bel ricordo il cielo che in cui mi
dissero che si era spezzato la calda
addosso cuore di quattro cd io chiavaro
si volevano bene che in realtà io gli
voglio bene
[Musica]
ma ancora più sotto sarebbero investiti
con l'automobile se sono sarà un
vendicativo ritendo i due cugini non
litigare ci hanno un mago aveva solo un
bisogno non del soccorso autore la
barton
ciao ragazzi bentornate non ho puntate
lucina puntata oggi va oggi farò una
tartare oggi io farò una tartare che è
uno dei piatti che piace tantissimo è un
piatto che mi piace moltissimo piatto
che io so fare benissimo quando mi metto
in cucina perché sono particolarmente
sono bravissimo appare a rio sono brava
a fare la fratellanza ho fatto oggi farò
nata la bara di vivere la parola di
canavese di carne pesce fare una tartare
di carne molto più buona di quella di
enrico avremmo bisogno di un trancio di
carne del vostro macellaio di fiducia
per tartare line perché non c'era limone
miele olio sale e pepe e salsa music e
anche nessuno di voi sa pronunciare
perché manchester invece pur se chef
workshop mostre scia di pesce avremo
bisogno salmone rigorosamente abbattuto
la protesta dell'anm un po di salsa di
soia per chi non mastica l'inglese come
me peperoncino un avvocato e delle
mandorle c'erano iniziamo con il
procedimento
certi momenti per prima cosa
trasformiamo la nostra carne in tartara
quindi vendiamo un coltello che andiamo
a fare delle fettine non mi sembra
bravissimo e possiamo farlo dire alle
persone che ci stanno seguendo fateci
sapere che secondo voi è più bravo siete
team kuja il multi merico invece di
essere sempre un presuntuoso non essere
presentate le realistiche
vogliamo fa cagare come scrive berger e
ragazzi stavano vincente si vedrà alla
fine tanto bravo gianmarco un po di
saggezza
sì ma tra un cavallo zoppo uno stallone
1 puntato lo stallone possiamo fare del
mattino delle chiavi persa anche la
tigella questo è il mio momento di
splendere non è il momento degli ok mi è
sempre rubato qualche dritta poi se vuoi
chiediamo bisogno della triste realtà
per te scorsi come ci si toglie eccoci
qui prima cosa tagliare il salmone a
cubetti una cosa importantissima della
terra e che abbia il morto si sa non
deve essere né patin e cicciotto nidil
arn enrico saprà benissimo che
ovviamente il taglio della carne è
diverso dal pesce quello che enrico
naturalmente non sa è che il pesce ti
puoi permette di farlo più grande della
carne perché la carne non sempre tenera
quanto il pesce pari e una giorgio
benissimo molto carini questi trancetti
di salmone mamma mia una precisione
pazzesca io ho studiato in giappone il
taglio del salmone questo guglielmo
ovviamente non lo sa e strategici sia
rigato usa e messaggi giappone
a breve ci sarà il rigo salmone crudo
vuol dire il giappone chi fa appena
vorrei che dice sì enrico sun
grazie dio venendo dalle sfuggire
culinaria dove abbiamo fatto sia tartare
di pesce che di carne sono professionali
è stata di niente che sono lo chef di
testuggine culinaria lo chef gabriele un
flash es
le fettine le trasforma in listarelle ma
lei che si è fan tritato qua punte
ritardo lo stai facendo di sicuro
grazie deve metter che anche due da una
parte di enrico io sono un giudice
imparziale parziale critica nemico
criticherò pure lui non so quando tu
riesca a criticare la perfezione
tranquillo ci riesco io
a questo punto e strisciolina e
ripetiamo eden siano trasformare oggetti
mi sembra che tu sappia il fatto suo
mediocre dai secondo me potrebbe fare di
meglio
sicuramente sì ma si può sempre fare ne
dobbiamo farlo quando non lo ha fatto
ridere io faccio tutte le cose con amore
e sicuramente fatto bene per stronzo ti
senti in forma questo sarà il morso
della nostra aveva questo è il morso
secondo enrico scilla è interessante il
sudore e parte della ricetta gianmarco
poi riprenderla e duecentomila modi e
sempre lui che è stata liana fetta del
salmone all'infinito atc può impegnare
poi cercare di fare nolan è sempre lui
che taglia summoner ok siamo quasi
arrivati alla fine
5 fateci sapere chi vi piace di più
giulia nuti merini anarchico o anarchico
per assurdo anno archi come è finito il
taglio del salmone
proseguiamo con la ricetta la diamoci le
mani sul burqa delle proprie o se è una
svampa turchi non spense svampa odore
cattivo prendiamo uno titone allontani
la colorado ancora deve fare prima non
posso marinare l'avvocato de valera del
nostro avvocato aspetta un interessante
vorrei evitare di andare oltre cioè a me
in realtà anche se la magliana
questo nome dal modo in cui viene
servita ok google non ce ne frega un ca
nun je frega un ca prendiamo la carne
mettiamola da parte un secondo a
riposare al fresco perché voglio che sia
bella bella fresca passiamo alla
sassetta questo non è tutta colpa non è
che dentro c'è un nocciolo quindi
andremo a proseguire con un taglio
trasversale diagonale circa una leghiamo
come ai grandi navigatori fin quando
andiamo dall'altro lato ci si separa
questo è il nocciolo o platea di
guglielmo come souvenir
andiamo a scavare questa tecnica viene
insegnata un grande chef gualtiero mi
sembra tutto perché andiamo a
circumnavigare tutto vasco de gama in
cucina mi sa che ce ne basterà un mezzo
spingendo metà si vedesse stato tanto in
giappone ha rigato un altro souvenir
procediamo a tagliare l'avvocato a
listarelle con altri sette anni per fare
cubi andava a unire i cubetti di
avvocato con il nostro salmon avvocato e
salmone preferisco vedere una
percentuale di salmone più elevata
rispetto all avvocato anche se in genere
pa percentuale sempre 50 50 abrami la
salsetta è una salsetta specialissima
che non l'ho mai fatto proseguendo
completamente l'istinto la pancia della
mia base avrà siena per eccoti qui olio
sale botta di pepe puntina di miele
questa è una mossa molto azzardata wii
una piccola botta di corse c a questa su
resta così non ti do santos spacchiamo a
metà online ping ping ping ping ping
ping ping
ok vi do un'altra botta con la scorso
un progetto ambizioso competitivo
intrigante prendiamo il nostro live
margot sbattiamo a metà ha un profumo
delizioso bisogna abbondare di succo di
lime perché lo so io
prendiamo il peperoncino lo three
turiamo e lo andiamo aggiungere al ain
non abbondiamo perché deve essere un
sentore piccante sta partendo un po
ovunque in realtà lavarsi le mani sempre
quando avete toccato qualcosa di
piccante perché sebbene passate negli
occhi fa male a me è capitato sia nelle
mappe altri cuginetti perché le varie
derby così a questo punto dobbiamo
impulse ion aree come se puntassimo
tutto quanto insieme a bola non so come
ho fatto nulla correggi neanche lavora
con almeno al sesto andiamo unire tutto
quanto la nostra tartare l'aver siamo
dentro una ciotola e a questo punto
gradualmente andiamo ad aggiungere la
salsa 12 paragoniamo la lasciamo per un
po in frigo a macerare e buona buona
paglia prima dico parla e quindi
servirla per il giudizio finale dei
giudici una tartara ci sta mettendo una
vita fate che lo sapete
dobbiamo aggiungere anche sesamo e papà
pelo non l'avevo detto davide è anche
questi due in sala decanato buoni un po
di soia un pizzichino di sale
andiamo ad unire rimaniamo molto
invitante la tartare di pesce ha bisogno
di pochi ingredienti e semplici se no
andiamo a coprire ciò che è la materia
prima mentre la carne ha bisogno di un
boost è un po più forte qui bisogna
rimanere semplici lasciamola a marinare
un po in frigo crediamo per
l'internamento abbiamo fatto macerare
per un po la nostra carne tiravano fuori
dal frigo cucchiaio e le diamo una
ripassatina per ritornare a vivere le
cose al punto giusto innocentissimo
coppa vasta ragazzi fondamentale davvero
in cucina sempre la sua mente per
comprarli
dipende leggera livellata papa magia
piccolo raga perché perfetta così quasi
più fuori e dentro per farvi capire
piccolo rari sapori sotto effetti fuori
e dentro che non giuro stop passiamo
alla saggia scegliamo un piatto e oggi
il bisogno di colmata gerola mia tartare
sulla chiappa avevo pensato a un
intervento ma cerchiamo la linea del
gluteo e un uomo per concludere grattata
di scorza di lime un po di sesamo e
papavero per dare colore
sette anni dopo cioè è stato estenuante
del papavero fatto una bellissima da far
bellissima devo essere certo allora
eccoci qua ho davanti a me la tartare di
pesce enrico arabe ma quei ragazzi cioè
ma chi ha fatto questa tartare è
stupenda consente a testa si presenta
benissimo l'aspetto è molto bello
l'unica critica che faccio è che lui ha
lasciato molti morbidi i cubetti e
appena rialzato è cominciato tutto
quanto a sfamarsi
ho sentito un che è tipico del car tar
venute bene a parte subito con
l'assaggio io sono quella resa di terra
un bambino grazie che bontà le rendo
subito un'altra forchettata buona posso
dire grazie della vittoria non mi
aspettavo un salmone del genere è
pazzesca di peperoncino è una roba
assurda pensavo che ci stesse malissimo
invece è pochissimo dotatissimo arriva
in coda ma pianissimo complimenti perché
questo piatto non ha nulla da invidiare
a un piatto di un qualsiasi ristorante
di pesce
ho temuto il piatto di guglielmo
assaggiato questo molto più delicato
molto più soft ed è una bomba rara
il terzo assaggio per farvi capire chi
c'è la fina posso perdere uno chef
significa anche cos'è questo come
sembrerebbe tanto pallino della coca il
piatto con prenotata il pallino
dell'avvocato cioè messo dentro
devo dire veramente una grandissima cup
da parte della cucina fotone inferiore a
quella di cui l 1 dori di mare non
sempre magari l'odore di mare e super
piacevole ci servivano un po più di
aromi secondo me però questo non è
troppo invadente il sette e mezzo sette
meno dobi secondo me un bel set se lo
merita il piazzamento fatto più che bene
otto e mezzo otto e mezzo passano poco
per arrivare un 9 si merita un bell'otto
la scelta di questo cupo di una
volgarità sapore di ragazzi forse non mi
bastano le dita
voto 10 il sapore 9 bob al 9 a tutto
questo aggiungo un mouse di meno 1 il
gusto è eccezionale un piatto soft
delicato ma che appaga il palato anzi
meno 2 per il semino il semino il coso
così che non abbia letto per barbara
garisti per questo piatto questo piatto
l'ho fatto col cuore
una ventina di euro 32 euro e
abbondantissima ragazzi e con trento
davvero pensare di fare un affarone 24
26 de li spendo il sorriso allora la
tartare di carne del mio nemico del mio
rivale eni si riempiono gli occhi il mio
fratello astro non ho fratello troppo
interessantissimo allora ha fatto quelle
nove è buonissimo commodore e abbiamo di
sapore
che miseria che buona io non pensavo di
riuscire a farla guglielmo guglielmo
l'imprevedibile guglielmo mi ha stupito
cioè cui lem devo dare subito un altro
assaggio ne prende un altro pezzetto
ragazzi veramente bravissimi tutti e due
andiamo per gradi aspetto e ovviamente
anche se come inferiore a quella di
enrico maria da bene fatta è fatta bene
lui sa cosa il colore che non mi rende
appieno rimpiazzamento inferiore
rispetto al salmone cioè la cremina
varie diarrea poi dovrete qui quindi io
do un sette e mezzo da 77 l'odore di
vino raga 98 e mezzo don no 20 aprile
narici i polmoni e il cruccio del coco
pops sapore di un calciatore mai
assaggiato una tartare di carne fatta in
questo modo complimenti guglielmo anzi
io amo la carne a tal punto che ho un 9
anche a questa ragazza 9999 ammetto che
il pesce era più semplice da fare perché
è più semplice della carne un meno 2
perché il taglio della carne è più
irregolari rispetto a colori di enrico
sicuramente perché il coltello era buono
non perché a quanto pagherei per questo
piatto o tirare le pure una bella
emozione 34 euro perché lo trovo
superiore a quello del ricordo al 17
euro somma comunque bravi tutti e due e
io preferisco il pesce alla carne quindi
ho detto tutto 22 euro
fatevene sa bene però poi cosa pensate
se sede di puglia e molti merico allora
diciamo che sono due prodotti veramente
eccezionali
se però dovessi scegliere il piatto che
mangerei più stesso probabilmente io
andrei sulla tartare di carne
sicuramente in una stagione calda come
questa una tartare di salmone è proprio
delicatezza pura fresa diciamo mangerei
prevalentemente quella di carmine nel
resto dell'anno
quella di pesce nel periodo estivo
appunto che comprende la primavera anche
se buonissime tutte e due ragazzi non so
veramente dove sbilanciarmi anzi lo
chiedo a voi mi congedo ciao ragazzi
sono arrivata solo per l'assaggio ora
tocca a me una faccia bellissima la
tartare per questo mi vedi dubbiosa
certi meloncino mattina quando con
invitate era una nota forte della mia
tartare virgilio l'arena l'edison una
maleducata però è buonissima era molto
bella quindi affetto ti do sette
pacchetti a lago i voti non si saranno
dati tipo cento non ho certo 25 odore
mi piace tantissimo quindi l'odore chi
dopo 10 favore normalmente avrei dato 9
perché è uno dei miei piatti favoriti
però visto e peperoncino devo da sei
siete sicuri che non mi avete cacciato
nel piatto io non mi fido di voi c'è il
peperoncino qui perché me lo mangio è
buona se è vero che la faccia stupita
per il fatto che sia buona affetto 4 ma
la ditta la mia 4
scusami però era mia era una delicata
all'interno del mio piatto preferito di
tutta la sua collezione non si
presentava benissimo sapore 7 mi piace
ma non ho capito che cosa altro c'è il
ministro e cos'è il tabasco
bush perché animate buon chester che io
non amo cena nel peperoncino a casa
mi dai un 6
non ci credo io non sono un amante di
questa roba così spinosa già ucciso
tagliate la fuori del vino è arrivata mi
hanno messa tenuta a cui davanti e io
dico quello che penso tu saresti
disposto a pagare per quel piatto che la
cifra giusta 12 euro 15 euro per quello
che ha detto 32 mangiamo il centro di
igiene mentale non sarei venuto a
prendere corato ma è questa sono
disposto a spendere ovviamente di più
senza peperoncino però la chiedere a 20
euro si comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video spero che vi
siate divertiti fateci sapere chi
secondo voi per me enrico ha vinto
iscrivetevi a questo canale per favore
dateci una mano attivati alla campanella
delle notifiche per rimanere sempre
aggiornati con i nostri contenuti
metteteci un pollice in su per l'impegno
vediamo martedì alle 12 con un nuovo
video